with residential real estate data
well
okay can everyone
I see my screen is popping up so hi
thank you for having me
um my name is taka my PhD is not in
computer science it's an astronomy
um and today I wanted to share with you
at a high level some
um kind of core facts about working in
real estate and how it differs from a
lot of other industry and in particular
digital native spaces and like both the
challenges that it faces and also the
Innovative opportunities that arise so
my talk will be at a much higher level
than
um some of the earlier more technical
talks but hopefully it'll be interesting
to everyone in here and
so right
um residential real estate has data that
is inherently really messy and I'll talk
about why that is and harder to navigate
than in digital native Industries like
e-commerce or streaming or social media
um and I'll also share some examples of
opportunities to innovate Solutions like
custom OCR models NLP and image
classification models
um
so business context because uh you know
you've probably never heard of our
company before Rock 360 is a financial
institution and we specialize in
residential real estate Investments we
fund business loans for investors that
include Fix and Flip investors that's a
colloquial term right so people who
might purchase distressed properties
renovate them and then resell them for
an investment profit or people who
purchase properties as rental
Investments
uh the company also works in things like
sourcing properties for and leads for
investors and and agents and also we
provide title insurance and property
insurance as well
um so one set of challenges and
opportunities is data quality
um data in this industry comes from many
sources
um
things like individual counties will
have their own processes and timelines
for recording deeds and mortgages uh
there there's data that comes from
Agents and Brokers and it's inherently
messy because it's originating for the
most part in manual and analog processes
it's not like you go to a website and
you make a purchase or you make an
impression on a website and all that
data gets recorded automatically in real
estate someone has to be there recording
the information signing the papers
notarizing it and then sending it to the
county clerk office where the county
clerks then go through the manual
process of recording and digitizing and
scanning it and as you might imagine
because there's so many people involved
in recording this data it's not
standardized at all the counties that
are next door to each other in the same
state might have completely different
processes for recording mortgages uh age
similarly agents and Brokers different
real estate companies uh will have
different ways of recording the
information or different cadences for
sharing that information and that means
that extracting data value-added data in
this space is is higher lift than in
other Industries and as a result not
many companies have fully mature data
products in real estate
um another class of opportunities is the
focus on unstructured data again if
you're in a digital native space there's
a lot of structured tabular data or
graph data that you can take advantage
of uh just by the virtue of it being
recorded and the company being able to
design the process and the data schemas
and and how it's stored and collected
but in real estate again you're
dependent on people taking pictures of
the property for instance you're
dependent on other people for drawing up
uh title paperwork or mortgage paperwork
or other other standards for notarizing
data and recording data so again it
comes it comes in all shapes and sizes
um and in particular for for our
business one of our the places where
we're active is where people invest in
distressed properties so these aren't
properties that you you know occasion um
you'll typically see on uh sites like
straight easy or Zillow these are kind
of unique properties that might be
really old or really decrepit or they
might not they might have a hole in the
floor they might not have a working
kitchen so these are kind of interesting
properties that are really idiosyncratic
and so that means that we as a company
if we want to take advantage of this
data and get value out of it we need to
innovate with custom models we need to
find ways of parsing these documents and
classifying these unique property images
um now once we've done the hard work of
normalizing the data and connecting
things this is one of the things that we
can do is we can look for uh in the
public record for people that look like
they've done a Fix and Flip transaction
for instance so someone bought a
property at a low price and in that same
entity either an individual or uh say an
LLC Corporation so that property say
about a year or so later at a profit
we've flagged that kind of transaction
as a potential flip
and then we can see okay of all the
people that have these transactions in
the public record uh can we do
unsupervised learning and figure out
what kind of investors are out there in
this space there's
um this is a medium data problem it's
not big data there's probably a couple
hundred thousand people that do this in
the United States as a whole so this is
a very limited data set nonetheless we
can do things like hey are there people
that always pay cash are there people
that go to a lot of different lenders uh
are there people that go to one specific
lender are there people that are entered
the space uh recently are there people
that have been doing this a long time
are there people doing this at a really
rapid Cadence and then using those those
sorts of variables uh we can then
cluster these people into different
segments and we might have different
marketing approaches or we might have
different hypotheses to follow up on
each of these clusters
um one thing we've done recently is uh
parsing documents at scale so we
leverage compute resources we use uh
directed graphs to Define and schedule
batch jobs again we're automatically
scanning the public record uh as well as
fetching documents from data vendors so
things like mortgage documents that are
a part of the public record but not
easily accessible
um
so this is one thing we can do I'll use
an optical character recognition
um so on the right is a snapshot of like
a typical
um public document and then we can do
things like uh parse the handwritten
parts we can parse specific uh kinds of
information and then
classify what kind of document it is and
then also identify the relevant
um relevant parts of the document
um but it's very intensive cost
intensive and compute intensive to run
OCR on every single page of every single
document so we'll do an object detection
model uh we use the YOLO algorithm to
find the relevant pages in every
document that might be 30 50 pages on
and then run OCR on the relevant pages
um so an example of an output might
might be just um not we extract tokens
and then we use uh by NLP models to
parse and classify the tokens so when
um you get you when you parse the
document using uh OCR you might say oh
this taka Tanaka based on the uniqueness
of that token and then the words around
that token uh we believe this is a
borrower this is a person
um and then you can say okay the F this
other token is a company name
um and so we can do this at scale uh we
we can parse hundreds of thousands of
documents in a matter of hours and then
uh extract that information and then
send it to our data warehouse for
further analysis and storage and things
like waking user for things like graph
Networks
um
and then uh another thing we do is is
obviously Machine Vision this is an
example of Auto clustering room types so
we parse through
um uh images of properties that are so
you know this is if you see something on
Zillow that those pictures would be in
this database and then we use
um we use a CLL to classify the room
types and then we use the last last
couple of layers for game news
clustering and yeah this is what we do
to to use the embeddings to classify
these these rooms into different room
types or outdoor images and then we can
say okay this this picture is a picture
of a bathroom and then we can train
another layer of models that says okay
is this bathroom in good condition
average condition or very poor condition
and
then we can uh once we have oh we do
have that model uh we deploy it uh on
the cloud and then we use it as an
internal evaluation app and we can say
okay here is the property here's all
here's all the metrics on it and
alongside all these all of these metrics
that we know firsthand from the data we
have we can also predict from the images
the overall condition of that property
um so those were some high level ideas
and some um projects that we're working
on to leverage
um you know things like optical
character recognition and computer
vision to
um to extract value out of this fairly
unorthodox or idiosyncratic data set
um it's very different from what's
typically done in at
your typical tech company I think
um and I think this is you know a
regardless of what kind of data you're
working with the challenge that
everyone's trying to solve is you want
to Define and measure business value
that part's relatively straightforward
but then you want to abstractly evaluate
what parts of your data are valuable or
relevant to to business value and that's
usually much more like much more
difficult and complex with unstructured
data like images and document scans as
opposed to you know logs up say user
behavior that you would get from an app
um so yeah I'll stop there uh that was
my high level talk
um and yeah I'm happy to take any
questions
this is very interesting
um I I don't have anything to do with
this but I just was was interested in
what about the quality of pictures like
we had some talks how people can can
um uh like kind of try to cheat the
system and here it is probably possible
too right so how do you address that
that's a great question
um we haven't run into that problem yet
one thing we are very mindful of is the
context of the image so like an image
that's taken by an agent
will be very well will be taken for very
different reason than a picture that's
taken by a contractor or by an appraiser
so one thing we do do is treat those as
different contexts and different sets of
images and we try not to mix them
um we're also aware of like the metadata
in the context like when is it from for
example right take
a posh condo in the Upper West Side of
Manhattan and take a bathroom or yeah
take a bathroom from a Podge condo in
Manhattan take a bathroom from like the
you know from like downtown St Louis or
the suburbs of Minnesota
um
those are going to have very different
standards for you know around the
question is this a nice bathroom
um so context around the data is
something that we work really actively
with to make sure that we're not
inferring the wrong thing by because we
have
um because we're treating all the images
as as a monolith
um yeah it's a difficult question and we
haven't yet run into the problem where
people are trying to game our system but
it's something that you know uh you know
Asians for example are Doctrine images
maybe they're using fisheye lenses maybe
they're digitally inserting Furniture
into the images these are things we
consider as well
thank you maybe we've invented the field
of adversarial real estate right here
today
uh thank you for letting us talk
um so we are talking about using uh
Russian audience to get value from the
data try to uh clean up the data limited
with other factors other aspects be more
valuable for example the timing for
example for fixed Flipper the overall
Market may be actually more
as much more contribution to the value
of the property uh yeah and the actual
data from the pictures that's right yeah
the pictures are we considered to be
like a correction to the overall data
like if you have a really nice looking
house and you're in like Westchester
County in a posh like a really upscale
neighborhood versus if you have a really
nice house in in I don't know South
Dakota or something like this you can
you can teleport the exact same property
to different parts of the country or
even within the same town you know
whether you're next to a park or next to
a construction site or a highway it
makes all the difference
um so absolutely we take into account
the location the trends in the data we
even abstract away model features around
are you close to a park and is it an is
it a is it a park that actually uh
raises the value of the property as
opposed to a park that might be more
like a marsh or a bog or on a like an
unsavory element of town
um so we tried to abstract act away like
the
local specific features of those
neighborhoods and then incorporate them
into into a model that can yeah that can
take those things into account
regardless of what where you are in the
country
[Applause]
to break for lunch Amy where's lunch
again right outside so you can't miss it
and we're going to Recon